what's going on guys greg and john here
so here's the deal
i'm reshooting this intro as i kind of
botched the first intro
so we need to redo it even though you
guys wouldn't know that
i could exactly like this is the first
intro but i'm giving you guys a spoiler
we really love this trailer
it was pretty awesome why do we watch it
because my brother
has an international channel called jaby
kawai he was really
resilient i'm making sure we covered
this trailer
and i was like fine he's doing so good
on his channel anyway that i was like
maybe he knows what he's talking about
he knows me we're related
so we watched it it's cool thanks jaby
he needs more subs yeah give it that's
the only reason we're doing this he's
struggling
anywho enjoy the reaction
[Music]
oh
[Music]
holy moly
looks like a zack snyder movie
[Music]
this is beautiful
[Music]
history
[Music]
unloaded
wow
oh my i could look like him one day if i
try hard enough you got this
man that that is the coolest
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
that was gorgeous absolutely that was
absolutely
gorgeous my god i can see how whatever
this is a sequel to got to be the most
profitable film of all time for at least
whatever this is a sequel to you haven't
you haven't seen kgf chapter one i mean
i'm i'm a huge fan of kgf i have
you know all the facts about it in my
mind dude you don't have to
lie to the audience no it happens they
need to know my credibility
all right you really don't have to lie
to the audience guys trust me
but seriously my brother warned me about
uh sarcasm sometimes they might not be
able to pick up on your sarcasm or my
sarcasm for that matter
so i think we have to approach this with
the utmost
sincerity moving forward as we talk
about this
we are both huge fans of the kgb
absolutely
we have seen the first one so many years
so many times enough times to fill a
whole real book yeah i
i'm a big i'm a big kgf fan i i
it's my honestly i it was my idea to
actually start up a channel that covered
more
you know international content
specifically more like indian
content maybe my brother should do that
instead because i i like to keep it more
for me it's more my passion more my
hobby and i just want to keep that for
me so
here why don't you go ahead and make a
channel make it your own business and
here we are today
in actuality guys i'm the really
encyclopedic one when it comes to the
films
over in india isn't that ironic he's
totally joking your style man this is
stuck in my style
jocking my stranger yup haven't seen the
first one
on imdb it says in the 1970s a pierced
rebel
rises against brutal oppression and
becomes a symbol of hope to the legions
of downtrodden people
and then this one it says the blood
soaked land of kohler gold
fields kgf has a new overlord now rocky
whose name strikes fear in the heart of
his
foes that's kind of like my brother and
i's relationship his allies look up to
rocky
as their savior again again
i am rocky brothers allies savior
the government sees him as a threat to
law and order
enemies are clamming for revenge and
conspiring for his downfall
bloodier battles and darker days await
as rocky continues on his quest
for unchallenged supremacy and on top of
that
it's bitchin it's badass man i was that
is the exact
kind of movie i would absolutely watch i
loved
the cinematography the visual effects
were absolutely gorgeous
and what i thought was really cool is as
heightened and
surreal as it was and it was like crazy
oh my god
it was looking i loved how they seemed
like it had so much emotion
and heart behind it as well and those
tend to be my favorite kind of action
movies no matter how
heightened it is no matter how some
things are just like come on that's very
unrealistic i think it's cool when you
can blend both
worlds where you could have that type of
level of oh my god that's insane and i
love it
backed with a lot of what just looks
like
moving heart yeah this was a really cool
trailer i was really impressed by
why he uh pressured me to watch it even
though i was the one who convinced him
to watch the first kgf movie i want to
put that on the record
after it was me who convinced him to
watch
the detail and i convinced him to watch
this trailer first i always want
everyone to know that
it was my idea first again my brother
warned me about my sarcasm and i got to
be
much more sincere so sincerity
it was my idea for him to start the jaby
koi channel yeah i mean i mean i don't
want to step on your expertise territory
that i that i have given to my brother
yeah that you've given to your brother
and to end to me because you know i mean
i
am only about second place in terms of
my you know knowledge of
an experience with bollywood foreign
films from india
if he if he can't get in touch with me
he gets in touch with john exactly i'm
the guy who kind of tells him everything
he knows if you can't do it and so yeah
i mean
given my expertise wasn't impressed by
this trailer in the least i think they
could do a lot better for reals
this was really dazzling i i did like it
did give me that vibe of like a zack
snyder movie
but with yeah way more like emotional
heft and when it started i was sitting
here going like man i was trying to kind
of
sort the era out in my mind because at
first it almost feels timeless like
you're watching some kind of
warrior epic which you are it seems like
but in a much more
sort of modern dystopian setting and so
to see
that beautiful use of yeah slo-mo and
these muddy looking environments but
that somehow don't
lose themselves into that muddiness like
a lot of hollywood films can
like yeah this looked really wrenching
and harrowing and also
just utmost badass like especially that
last clip
a just the cars blowing up in slow
motion and the guy walking right up with
the cigarette like that's the
coolest thing i've probably seen all of
last year and these few days of 2021.
i i used to smoke cigarettes the closest
i came to
replicating that was one time i
um i was boiling some eggs and
then i left the pot on for for way too
long
and then the pan was just smoking uh
yeah that's right boiled eggs in a pan
it was stupid to me i put the cigarette
up to there and it didn't work because
the water
uh was still dripping from the pan and
so i actually
ruined the cigarette and then i gave him
smoking from there
but that's what that moment really
reminded me of and that's why i got so
excited
i'll pick up smoking again just because
of that on your behalf that's true yeah
and jaby kawai smokes
because of us yeah absolutely just want
to make that clear guys
if you haven't done so already jaby
koei's video only got to number five on
the trending page in india
so why don't you guys go ahead watch his
video again
help get it to number four he's all
about that trend also
subscribe to us if you want i think that
really
we're much more in tune with with
everything than he is
i don't know why this whole video is
about why we're better than him
and we know more than him but i thought
it was important that everyone knows
that you gotta tell it like it is man
hit that like button i'll catch you guys
soon
peace hope you like the video i hope
this is what he wanted we don't want it